Coffee on a Tuesday in 27.
Okay,
so if you're like me,
it wasn't or it won't be until the last
semester of college.
Undergrad when you really catch the bug
of learning and there must be a thousand
reasons for this.
Belated development reasons which are
universal and so forgivable.
The most conspicuous being that high
school literally rips it out of you in
favor of a more relevant apparatus.
That is a system for navigating social
relationships.
In other words,
a system for how to be cool.
I'm not totally sure that it's a bad
thing.
This development of a social aptitude.
I actually think that there is such a
thing as cool and I would define a cool
person as someone who engages others
with their ideas.
Someone who is receptive enough to
friends and acquaintances and even
strangers to see when the other is
clearly not interested in what you're
saying.
Telling a story that your audience can't
possibly relate to is not cool.
Boasting is not cool.
Isolation is not cool.
I don't go in for winners and losers,
but I do go in for.
Cool.
Okay,
so there was this one time in eighth
grade when I was acting out in class,
being loud and clownish and stupid and
my teacher,
Mr Leventhal told me to go wait outside,
you know that horrible exile of
secondary school when you get
reprimanded and everybody sees it and it
was even worse because I like this
teacher,
you know,
we were supposed to be friends.
Well,
he came out into the hallway with a
conciliatory look and said to me,
Evan,
look,
I know you're funny.
Everyone in that class knows you're
funny,
but being funny doesn't mean a damn
thing if you don't have timing to this
day.
That is the best.
Certainly the most influential advice
I've ever gotten.
There's no question that it changed my
life.
Not right away,
but good advice never does.
Gradually it sunk down and took hold and
in moments when in the past I would have
blurted out some thoughtless vulgarity.
I instead opted to keep silent,
to listen,
to feel the waves,
have a conversation and say something or
tell a joke only when the moment was
prime for it.
It's a lot like surfing and surfing.
You're going to wipe out a lot in the
course of getting better.
No matter how good you get,
the day will never come when you've said
your last idiotic thing.
Word of advice.
Don't trust anyone who never makes a
fool of him or herself because that
person is nailing.
The more we grow,
the more this mastery of timing augments
our ability to get along in the world.
It has its application in a perfectly
executed joke,
yes,
but timing isn't everything.
It's in the way we treat our family,
our friends,
our teachers,
our bosses,
our employees.
A good relationship depends on knowing
when you should,
for example,
be deferential when you should stick up
for your opinion on understanding when
it's okay to offer help to a friend and
when it's okay to ask for it.
Timing plays a huge part in your
writing.
A good story is not interesting,
but for the rhythm at which it's told,
the same goes for a good speech or a
good lecture or a good vlog.
I do think that it's a natural part of
growing up,
but it's one that becomes so obsessive
in the early years that the desire to
learn for learning's sake gets pushed to
the fringe because it holds no value in
social currency and it's an obsession
that lingers into the first years of
college because we're also anxious to
fit in and that's natural too,
but I think eventually it dawns on us
that what it meant to be cool in high
school is not really going to be enough
to make a happy life.
After graduating college,
I became so extremely frustrated with
how little I really knew.
It seemed to me that all my knowledge
was like so many free floating clouds
that had no connection.
What I learned was easily forgotten and
often contradictory.
I had the timing stuff down,
but now I wanted to know things.
I wanted to know everything,
so I resolved to start at the beginning
with the foundation of all knowledge
philosophy and I began to read like I
sometimes eat potato chips ferociously
and the result of all that was this a 36
page discourse on truth.
Summing up everything that I thought and
believed I had it printed up at Kinko's
and I sent a copy out to all my family
and friends as if to say,
here,
this is what I know and this is who I
am.
If you're interested to read it and you
can find a link to an online copy in the
dubliner.
I just reread it two years later and I
don't agree with everything that's in
there,
but that's to be expected.
There's still a lot of things in there
that I do agree with.
For me,
it symbolizes more at the beginning of
the period of my life when I became
obsessed with learning and it's an
appetite that is perpetually
unquenchable.
It never gets boring because there's
always something more to learn.
The timing was ironically not so great.
All of this happened after I had already
graduated college.
After the countless thousands of dollars
we're already spent on an education that
I wish I could go back and get more out
of.
I would have taken so many more liberal
arts classes if I had to do it again,
but Aha to the point of this circuitous
video.
You can do it again on this phone.
I have an APP called Itunes u on it.
There are literally dozens of courses
from schools like Stanford,
Yale,
and Harvard.
Do you know how much harvard costs and
tuition per year?
Do you know how much work you have to
put into get into that school and they
put their courses on my phone for free.
I mean,
am I the only one who thinks this is
awesome right now.
I am taking a course,
a Stanford course called the
international system in the 20th century
on my couch with a beer for no money at
all and I don't have to do any of the
home.